do you have doubts about the leadership
of the Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
I do and I have and I think their been
confirmed what doubts did you have my
doubts are that if there is very little
sense of rule of law respect for human
rights dignity and you know the
allegations that are made so far don't
know yet are not inconsistent with the
way the Kingdom would act and and I so
I'm very worried that the president
seems to have a love affair with
autocrats and president Trump Trump
president Trump yeah and the idea that
he's already making excuses before the
facts are known as is typical but it
hurts us internationally if the
allegations are true and that the crown
prince of Saudi Arabia ordered the
killing of this Saudi dissident who
wrote a column for The Washington Post
should there be consequences absolutely
positively this was a permanent American
resident in a permanent green card this
is as close as you can get to
citizenship he lived here and the idea
that we would not take retaliation
against them is ridiculous what kind of
retaliation well I think we do well we
could cancel the arms sales look they're
not doing a whole lot to change the
equation in the Middle East they got us
involved in a war indirectly by using
our equipment that is killing thousands
of innocent people
this is Yemen yeah so I look I I don't I
just don't know why we this
administration seems to feel the need to
coddle autocrats and dictators from
Putin to Kim jong-un to you know Duarte
I mean I I don't understand it why do
you think President Trump does that I
don't want to speculate in my worst
fears but either he doesn't know what
he's doing or he had
absolutely combo notion of what allows
America to lead the world